[inaudible].
So I think I, the first time we
sat down, I think I asked you this,
so this seems like the right segue for it.
So for everything that we've talked about
here and the addiction to age and all
that,
there's gonna be a certain amount of
people that are watching this and going,
wait a minute, Glenn Beck was one of
the people that was peddling this stuff.
Huh?
I as well,
I think I know you pretty well right now.
And I feel like you are honest
in your beliefs and you've,
you've had some mayor Kulpa is about some
of the things you've said. Even just a,
you got into something on Twitter with
my friend Marge and new eyes and new
fully.
He,
he sent you a clip of something that
you did about him a couple of years back
and you fully, you apologized
immediately. You said,
I'd love to talk to you and learn
more and all of those things.
I just asked that to him today and what
he is he coming in? Yeah. And I know,
and I loop you guys in
an email, right? So, uh,
is there anything you can add to that
about just sort of how you've changed?
Like, do you remember a moment,
was there something about that?
Because maybe there are people that are
going down that road right now that's
still want more of the outrage and
stiller is still are, you know,
as they call it, shit posting on
Twitter and the rest of it. Um,
if you were trying to get
somebody to turn back,
no, cause they were really
personal experiences.
I went from the, you know, that,
that global poll that comes out
around Christmas time, you know, uh,
most admired man in the world.
Yeah.
I was tied with the pope
just behind Nelson Mandela.
Okay. That's insane. That's insane.
12 months later, I'm no longer
on that list. I'm hated. Yeah.
I was saying the same things, CNN
that I was saying on Fox. Okay.
So that was confusing.
Um,
and it was,
you know,
you can't be hated by half of the country.
I mean,
unless you're just, um, you
know, maniacal, you know,
egomaniac that is just beyond
any kind of redemption.
You cannot be hated by half
of the country. You know,
a a false hero for the other
half of the country and not go,
okay,
I'm not that.
I don't think I'm that. Yeah. So who am I?
What part of it most people will go,
well,
they spent millions of dollars
to destroy my reputation,
to take things out of context.
And they did.
But I also did things because
my philosophy at the time
was if I can get enough
eyeballs, if I can get people to
watch, which puts me in leader Hosan,
you know, seeing engage Levis that
can get people to watch. Yeah.
Then I present them with facts and
my opinion of where it's going.
It forget about everything else.
They'll hang onto the facts and
someone in the press, we'll go,
I hate that.
So I'm going to prove him wrong.
They never did.
They never would look at the facts.
So this is always where they just want
to belittle you and shame just to silence
you
and I, and I helped them.
Okay. I added to that.
So I'm not saying it's somebody else.
I am taking my, my responsibility,
but the biggest thing is
now on the other side,
I can look and say, wait,
all of you in the press,
you said I was the worst.
Let me go get the transcripts.
See what I just said?
That's what you said to the 10th power
right here. It's, they won't work.
It's wrong and it won't work,
but nobody wants to do that.
Nobody wants to look. They, everyone
wants to point to the other person.
Nobody's willing to go.
I said me,
but you think that 70%
that you mentioned before,
maybe starting to do that a little
bit. I mean, again, I'm trying,
if I'm trying to find how to
get out of this thing. Okay.
And I think that 70% where I'm meeting,
I know it's a select group
because they're coming,
they're coming to see me and
Jordan and take 70% take 17
yeah, 10 committed, 10%
committed changes. The world.
17 is your tipping point,
so it doesn't take all of us.
Revolution was fought by
about 20% of America. Okay?
Those were the ones who said,
I believe in this.
We have to,
we have to understand,
and a lot of the book is
about postmodernism and
how that works and what its
goals are. What does
postmodern even mean? What is,
what's the modern world?
It's not about a machine.
It's about the scientific process.
It's about exploration and empirical
data and testing a and B and living with
the results. That's what the modern
world is. So when you realize,
so you would say postmodern really is
auntie modern in essence because it's
going against the ways that we've
been able to measure anything.
The way we've been able to look at
only you can,
when you don't understand postmodernism
and you read the headline, which I did,
math is racist.
You either go,
these people are out of their can
minds and I can't take it anymore.
Or you can say how?
How did they get there?
When you asked that question,
you start to go and peel the layers down
and you see the core of this idea good
or bad that what came out of the modern
era of the enlightenment was this and
they say
this is bad. They say this is bad.
That. That really is it. Yeah,
and anything that holds
this up must be destroyed.
If that's math, if that's
you. Doesn't matter.
Yeah.
If you understand that it's all about
deconstruction and deconstruction is all
about chaos.
You must not do anything
to hasten the chaos.
You have to restrain yourself. The best
way to fight this isn't about Gandhi. Oh,
I want to beat just like Jesus.
No,
I want to win and the best way to win is
to restrain yourself from adding any of
the chaos. Be Clear, be stuffed, spoken.
Be the person that everybody in the room,
when everybody is arguing,
they kind of look around the room and
there's maybe three people over there that
are just laughing and having fun and just
because you will be the one that will
control the room. In the end, everybody
else will kill themselves, but the the,
the majority of people
will go, oh, I hate this,
and they'll make their way over to you.
That's what we have to do.
We have to stop fighting
on the stupid stuff.
The stupid stuff.
Yeah.
Gay wedding cakes. Good God, man.
Homosexuals right now, today in parts
of the country. What do you say?
We start there?
What do you say?
We talk about something that
really makes a difference.
Really makes a difference. We get
to the gay wedding cakes. Yeah,
let's be good people first.
Yeah.
It's so interesting how people just don't
want to do the intellectual work and
now it's like we have these, we have these
phones, we have endless distractions.
To the point that perhaps 20 years ago
you might have a moment standing on a
corner waiting for a friend to go
to dinner where you'd have to think,
but we can distract ourselves to the point
where we actually never have to think
anymore. When was the last time
you just stood somewhere? I mean,
I know you're aware of all of this
stuff, but when it was, let's have you,
Glenn Beck just stood somewhere on the
corner waiting for your wife to meet you
and you weren't looking at your
phone or you were in, you know,
I him to do what you did,
but I can't do it for a month.
I have too many employees.
That's the problem. I only
have like five [inaudible].
I, I, I try to do it once a week.
Don't make it every time,
but just,
I'm not going to be online.
Do not pick up your device,
go out on a date with your
wife and do not carry a device.
You don't have it with you. Um,
that's important. And it's important,
Dave, because I learned
something with my alcoholism.
I was struggling with so many
things when I was younger,
um, that I didn't want to think about.
I didn't want to think about it.
I didn't want to think about the
things that I had done in my life.
The things that I was, oh, poor me about
it. Just didn't want to think about it.
And I would turn on the radio and I turn
it up loud and I'd be driving my car
and I never really
consciously connected the two.
It got to the point where it was so
bad that if I didn't have something to
distract, I would literally be
by myself and I go la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Just to block out my thoughts.
Okay. That's a problem.
And I realized when I
was finally no longer,
I was sober and not, uh, uh,
and not just not drinking,
uh,
was the time that I was driving someplace
and I must've been driving for about
an hour and I hadn't turned anything on.
And I realized at one point I'm just
driving and I kind of come to kind of come
to thinking, you know, about what's in the
car, what's happening? And I'm like, oh,
I wonder what's on the rate.
Oh my gosh,
I've been alone with myself
and my thoughts for an hour.
That's a sign of mental
health. Yeah, we're sick.
We're sick.
So in the, uh, in the book
in the, in the forward,
you a very graciously,
and I'm humbled that you did it,
you included me in a list
of names of people that you,
uh, that you put in there.
Um,
and
Ben had this and I wrote,
I even wrote to, to Ben,
I wrote is an inscription on this page.
Yeah. Like two days later he calls me,
oh my gosh. We were with each other
for two days. And he was like, hey,
thanks very much. And then like at
midnight one night I get this text,
he's a busy guy and I know to those who
are willing to step out in front of the
crowd to question reason and
have dangerous conversations,
men with whom I may strongly disagree
with at times, but we'll all,
I will always consider
[inaudible] founders of reason
and contemporary heroes.
Ben Shapiro, Dave Ruben, Jordan
Peterson, Bret Weinstein, Sam Harris,
Jonathan Sacks,
pendula,
Joe Rogan. So I thought, I don't
want to make this about me.
So the one that I thought
was most interesting,
they're actually with Sam Harris
because I suspect you guys probably,
if he disagrees with Jordan Peterson
on everything, pretty much everything,
policy, existentialism meaning
a life, the whole damn thing.
You guys probably disagree
on everything plus one.
I don't know if we went through no,
and I thought,
well this is what it's all about.
This is what it's all about. So,
but would you have ever, I mean, 20
years ago, if you were writing a book,
you would,
that's when I,
I've often joked that my library is a
library of a serial killer because I was
too broke to actually go
get a formal education.
So I would go to Barnes and
noble or the library and I'd go,
who hates each other,
this opinion,
who hates this opinion,
that person.
And I would read them both and
I would look at him and say,
is there any, anything where they
intersect because I know is true.
If both these people are from
opposite ends of the spectrum.
And they both say this is true.
I know that one line in
both books is true. Okay.
So start small and build
the basis of truth.
And what motivated me was aligned
from Thomas Jefferson, uh,
that he wrote to his nephew Peter car.
Peter's parents had both died.
Um, when his dad was ill, he said,
can you please educate my
son when he comes of age?
So Thomas writes this unbelievable letter,
you know,
in mathematics you have to do this.
In literature, you have to do this.
The last thing is religion. And
I love it. It's changed my life.
MMM. When it comes to
religion, above all things,
fix reason firmly in her seat
and question with boldness,
even the very existence of God for if
there be a god he must surely rather
honest questioning over blindfolded fear.
We break down on the word honest,
honest questioning you and I liked each
other and get along because you haven't
asked me a setup question and I've
never asked you a set up question.
It's an honest question. Hang on
just a second. But that right.
But that, that is it and that's
good. But yeah, that keeps you young,
that keeps you alive. The minute used
to, I knew my father was going to die.
My father was the kind of guy who always
had a book in his back pocket. Okay.
Self educated man.
And uh,
he's always exploring and questioning
and he was so granola fruit loop,
be one with the universe kind of guy.
And I called him up.
We were best friends for a long time.
And um,
I'd call him sometimes two, three times
a day. And we just talk about books,
we're reading and things. Did you hear
this opinion? What do you think of this?
We talked about the future, the
past, all of it. And I said, Dad,
I just read this fantastic book.
You have to read this.
I'm going to send it to you.
And he said, hmm, that's okay.
And I said, alright. And he said,
I'm tired. I'm tired. I
think I've learned enough.
Huh? Three years later
he was, he was gone.
When you,
when you are not,
we are built to explore.
And when you're not exploring what's left,
well,
what would you be doing
if you weren't doing this?
I told my wife when she married me,
and this is one reason I've lucked
out so much. My wife hates fame.
She hates wealth.
She hates red carpet,
ate all of it cause she married
me and her family was like,
you're not gonna marry him. He is
a loser. He's not going to imagine,
he's not going to amount to anything.
Um,
when she married me because I'm the
first out of every generation that we can
find going back. I'm the first
male that has not become a baker.
And so I would probably probably be a
chef in some place or I'm not good at
baking.
I was just gonna say, would
you bake me a cake? That's
no, I'm not good at
baking. I am good advice.
My father said baking
sun is about formulas.
Cooking is winging it.
Yeah.
And I'm not good with
formulas to inpatient.
You're, you're a definitely
a, a wing in it Kinda guy.
So generally speaking,
do you feel it's funny,
the first half of what we've done here
was sort of fire and brimstone, sort of,
or laying out, you know, this is, this
thing could really go off the rails.
I think the last 20 minutes or so
it's been a little more hopeful.
I'm an optimistic catastrophist
you do not want me,
you do not want to be anywhere near
me on the titanic until we get to the
iceberg. As we're going into the
iceberg, I'm saying, are you kidding me?
Have you counted the lifeboats?
There's not enough lifeboats.
We're headed into cold area.
If there is, if these people,
they're going to be irresponsible, they're
not going to pay attention to the ice,
but they're arrogant. They're gonna
hit the iceberg and all going to die.
Okay. Soon as we hit that iceberg,
I'm there. We're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it because I
believe that when people are awake,
they will awaken to who they truly are.
And I think Americans are different.
We have this spirit us of exploration.
We're the people who cross the oceans
were the people that cross the Rockies.
I have to tell you if,
if I were alive during the
time when we were exploring,
I d I don't even think I would
have made it past the Missouri,
but definitely I would have gotten
to Denver and went, okay guys,
I am not going any. We're
not crossing. Okay. I always
think every time I'm on the,
uh, on, uh, what is it? The
five, uh, that goes by the,
the Getty Museum, which, which is,
that fell the four oh five zero five.
Every time I'm on the four
oh five we bumped to la.
So I see the Getty museum up there and I
think if I were a pioneer and I made it
this far,
I would have built my house in this valley
and people would have been on the top
of the hill going, you should see
what's on. And I'd be like, I am done.
But generally people are explorers,
they're good and they're,
they're hardy and they want to live.
I think they do want to live and they
want to live in peace and harmony.
I think that about the Palestinians
and the Israelis when if you could,
and I've done it,
I've done it.
When you don't have a camera in somebody's
face and nobody knows you're talking,
you sit down in a house of a Palestinian
and most likely average person,
they're like, I don't
really care. I mean I just,
I want to raise my family.
I just want to be left alone.
I want to be able to eat maybe
a little extra money, sole life,
and I can go off for a nice weekend.
That's people.
It's when everybody starts
telling them it's them, you know,
that's keeping you down.
That's what their struggle.
You find it weird in a way that,
um,
we're thought of as political beast
because in a certain way we really haven't
talked about politics here.
And I find now,
I'm probably less interested in politics
now today than I've ever been in my
adult life in a bizarre way. You
know what I mean? Like I still,
I still love it at some level,
but like what we're doing here and what
I think the real conversation happening
in the world right now is,
is not political.
There's a class of people that are trying
to make everything political and keep
you confused and controlled.
Flooding the Russians.
Do you see the latest the
Russians, believe it or not,
the Russians, one of their,
one of their,
yeah,
campaigns happened when,
uh,
I don't remember which was that the last,
the last star wars movie, I think. Oh,
I did see this. They said that, uh, the
last jet I, that is Russian bots, right?
Well,
that's what Ryan Johnson,
I guess was there is evidence that they
were s they were politicizing the movie
that they were, they were putting out, oh,
you're not gonna like that
robot because that robot,
it's all about social justice. I remember
seeing it. The movie did suck and we,
you know, yeah, he's
here. I'm with you. Yeah.
But what I'm saying is we have outside
influences that are trying to make
everything about politics.
Read the book,
defining Hitler is the best,
best explanation of what
happened in Germany. Ever
written by a guy at the time
as a warning to the west.
Go and you don't know what,
you don't know where we've been.
You don't know what's happening
here. Warning. And so he,
he really gives you a,
a look at what was happening prior to,
and you can see it.
You're like, oh my gosh,
that's the world trade center going down.
Oh my gosh, that's this. You can see it
repeating it. And he says, right,
right around 1933
nothing is not political.
There is not one topic
that is political. When did this happen
to us? It's incredible. I mean just,
you know,
I never watch cable news anymore and I
don't even watch sports channels anymore
because it's all political.
But when I'm doing cardio,
I'll just flip channels and everything.
You go to his political,
the view is now always political. If
you're watching women's, you know,
basically women's television in the,
the ESPN now is political all the time.
I mean every channel.
So you'd probably turn on the food channel
and there's some political situation
happens.
Let me tell you something
that I've never said out loud.
Only person I think that even knows
it in my own company. Oh, Stu,
my executive producer,
I couldn't tell you any of the names of
the people that are running for House
and Senate. I'm on talk
radio. I don't care.
I don't care.
I pay somebody to look at that.
Tell me what's the balance of
the House for the audience?
It does not affect me one iota
except in the big picture.
Which movement is moving. I just, it,
it's a waste of our time.
Think of how many man hours America
has lost in the last 15 years.
Think of what we could have
done with all of this time.
Forget about the money.
Is that the best argument for basically
sort of classical liberalism or
libertarianism that if we
could just reign this thing in,
that not only could you live however
you want it to live? Basically,
if the government was just
pretended protecting your,
your life and your property,
your rights, your rights, right.
That not only would that be good
because you could do what you want,
but it would actually, Evan would
save you money and see, Oh yeah,
you'd heal.
You'd still have it.
You'd have it still on the local side,
which would be great that that would
actually, you know what I mean?
Is You'd still have people who had tried
to take the local area and they'd be
the big boss of the area, so you'd
have those things you'd have at least,
you'd have a little more control over
that you could control it or you could
move to the next town.
You know what I mean?
San Francisco can be as
weird as it wants to be.
They could live in, you
know, six feet of human poop.
That's fine.
If that's what you want to do.
You know there's an app for the human
poop. Did you know that? I'm not kidding.
There's actually an APP that tells you
where human poop is on the streets in San
Francisco.
Literally going back.
It's insane.
It's insane. I, I remember saying,
I remember saying people,
there's gonna come a time where you,
we will not recognize your country.
What you thought was solid will be liquid.
What you thought was real will be false.
You're not going to recognize it.
We're not only so far past that
point now too, where you're like,
I don't even know who anyone is. I don't
know what is real, what's, I don't know,
up and down anymore.
We're so far past that,
but what's incredible
and this is a good thing,
or could it a good thing because of
technology by 2030 you're not going to
recognize it. Anything.
Nothing will be the same.
It will be the difference between looking
at our lives in 2030 looking back and
going, Dave, you remember
2018 when we sat,
it will be as different than as if
we were sitting in now and going,
man, can you imagine what 1920
was like? It's going to be
be that different. You know,
this reminds me of a align,
I interviewed Peter Teal a couple
of weeks ago and he said that um,
crypto is for libertarians
and AI is for authoritarians.
And I think that that sort of gets to
the heart of what you're saying because
maybe what's going to happen
here is that as our institutions,
our political institutions, academic
institutions, media institutions,
as they become so big,
they can't sustain themselves anymore.
So maybe we will sort of break
off into smaller communities,
whatever that means. And we'll
sort of is about, that's what the,
that's what the declaration
of independence and the
constitution encouraged,
encouraged,
break off, do your own thing. You
should be a little laboratory,
be a little laboratory.
You come up with some of the great,
I'm sure the other states and the other
cities will adopt it. If, if it works,
we're all love it. Stop, stop.
It's, it's not one experiment.
Why are we so, Lillian, why
are we so afraid of that?
Because I pushed that idea constantly
and it's like, you know, just that the,
that the laboratory should exist so
that if you want low taxes, you go here.
But then if that screws over the schools
then go somewhere else or whatever it
is that, that play. But people
are really afraid of that.
That somehow we're not actually America
if we don't live under the same exact
laws everywhere at which, as
you said, is the antithesis of,
of the founding documents.
People just have been convinced
that people are not trustworthy.
Well, people aren't trustworthy if they
never get in trouble. If they never,
banks are not trustworthy.
If they never have to pay for their
own mistakes, they're not trustworthy.
Um,
when you have to pay for your own mistake,
you learn when people generally become
trustworthy. You brought up Peter Teal.
People ask me all the time, are
you concerned about deeply? Yes.
I'm concerned about d platforming big
time and especially Dave with what's
coming with,
with deep fakes and all the,
there is trouble on the horizon.
Peter,
every time somebody says something,
I always say,
you know the guy who can solve this Peter
Teal because we need a platform and I
mean left and right. A platform
whose charter is the bill of rights.
That's it.
If you agree with the bill of rights,
you're not trying to shut anybody up.
You believe in these things,
these human principles, what make us
human. Come on, put your thing on here.
We're not going to kick anybody off.
We're not going to do anything. Is this a,
this a place where speech
will be protected because
thoughts are supposed to be
dangerous.
It's only the dangerous thoughts
that led us to the moon.
It's only the dangerous thoughts that
invented television or the Internet.
It's a dangerous thought that that said,
I wonder if I can make fire like the
sky does or that's a dangerous thought.
You're going to burn everything
down. Well, they didn't. Yeah.
Well, I can't say more
than if you saw my, uh,
chat with Eric Weinstein
a couple of weeks ago.
The billionaire class is talking now.
So there,
there is some upbeat to hear that. Yeah.
One other thing on that and then, uh,
I will let your staff do other, I assume
they have other work to do around here.
You people do another work around here
that you got things to do today to, um,
do you think that if we get
out of this thing and it,
and it's basically okay out of this sort
of morass that we're in right now and
that is basically okay that we'll
look back on this and think, whoa,
there was something really good
that came out of it because
yeah. Barack Obama was my
biggest nemesis. You don't know.
You don't know what it's like to come
under attack until the president of the
United States. I've had
two of them now. Yeah.
Is coming after you directly and using
the force of his friends and allies to
come after. Who was the other
one that went after? It was not,
Trump's probably was drunk. Yeah. During,
but yeah, at the beginning. The beginning.
Yeah.
So
call you after you basically were
like, all right, I'll, no, no, nothing.
You didn't get anything?
Nothing. No, no, no. All right.
And I'm fine with that. Yeah. Um, uh,
what was what we were talking about
that will come out on their side,
but we'll look back and this is getting
Obama and Donald Trump have been some of
the best things that's ever happened
to me. And I don't mean financially or,
you know,
whatever.
I mean as a man because they've both
taken me by the lapels and shoved me up
against the wall and said,
what is it you really
believe we are so blessed.
Do you know that really,
even my father's generation,
he came at the end of, you know,
he was born in 26 so he, you know,
he saw World War II and stuff,
but anybody who really grew up
in lived from 1946 until now,
we really have been very blessed.
But we've also been cursed.
No one has had to have
everything about them challenged.
I'm a better man.
You're a better man because every time
somebody throws you up against the wall,
we will be a better country.
We'll be a stronger, more vibrant,
more free people if we behave ourselves
and learn from what's throwing us up
against the wall. That's how I ended
in interview back. Good word rhetoric.